the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
written to the Home Secretary Suella
bravaman that is to make clear that
following an investigation he does not
believe that suela Braverman has broken
the ministerial code this of course
relates to a speeding fine that she
incurred last summer we're joining me
now on set is our political
correspondent Sam Coates uh Sam what do
you make of this it's a significant
breaking news in richardsonac has
decided to keep Home Secretary Suella
bravaman in post all the way back on
Saturday night the Sunday Times and the
men on Sunday revealed that Zoella
bravaman had been having conversations
with her officials about a speeding
penalty now it's never been quite clear
what exactly she asked for did she ask
perhaps for the points to be canceled
did she ask for her officials simply to
investigate ways where she could go for
a speed awareness course but not be seen
by other participants perhaps do it uh
privately now there is an allegation
that the labor party made that this
breached the minister real codes and if
you break some ministerial code then
potentially you are out now at the time
Richardson app was uh at the G7 in Japan
he has returned to the UK looked at the
matter looked at the emails uh
underlying the matter and this morning
uh there's been an exchange of letters
that makes clear that Richardson is
keeping Zoella bravaman in place let me
just read it
Richardson says I have consulted with my
independent advisor now that's Laurie
Magnus who he brought in to look at
things like this and he is advised on
this occasion no further investigation
is necessary and I have accepted that
advice on the basis of your letter in
our discussion my decision is that these
matters do not amount to a breach of the
ministerial code so she's he Richie
sunak is going to make the argument on
the basis of the facts not that we've
got but that he's got that Zoella
Brotherman should stay in place it has
to be said that had he taken the
alternative course of action to force
her to resign there would have been a
huge route around with the right the
party around at a point where it's the
home secretary's brief on Thursday
coming unto scrutiny with possibly 750
000 being the figure for the latest net
migration uh he's decided not to have
that route to keep her in in place but
people will accuse like labor are of
British in that being weak